um but today I am here to do a lot of
things mostly to educate and Inspire
hopefully that's the plan we'll see how
it goes uh what I'd mostly like to do is
point out how cute this penguin is
how do we all feel about this penguin
open question good penguin
awesome cool thank you yeah clapping is
fine whatever audience knows you would
prefer I've just knocked over my water
bottle right so hopefully you understand
me I have come from England and I have a
terrible accent so we'll have to deal
with that
um but what I'd like to do is talk to
you today about mutation testing and in
a talk that I'd like to call fear the
mutants love the mutants so before I get
started
um I do want to say this company has
paid for me to come here they've paid
for my flight from England so I am going
to mention them thank you
um so we do Communications apis we've
got a booth we're going to raffle off an
Xbox in about an hour's time if you want
to go see us and do that that's fine
that's all I have to say more
importantly though and the reason I'm
mentioning it is because
um so I actually learned about mutation
testing last year because I added it to
an SDK that I maintained for this
company so I actually learned about this
last year and what I want to do is share
with you what I've learned and share
with you the kind of Journey I took
and so it's so weird not to be able to
walk I usually walk around I'm used to
like getting my steps and I'm like like
I have to stay like here apparently so
I'll try I'll try and do that a little
bit you'll see me moving so um I just
like to say
that I I may have the loudest voice in
the room I definitely do but what I'd
like to say is that I'm not the real
protagonist here because the real
protagonist is Henry now this is Henry
how do we feel about Henry Q penguin
awesome awesome I know most people just
came here for the Q Penguins so don't
worry we've got you we've got a lot more
of those so don't worry about that right
so
Henry is awesome Henry's going to be
very useful soon but right now we're not
going to talk about him too much but
just keep him in your mind because he's
going to really tie everything together
later on before we get there though this
is going to be quite audience
participation heavy so if that's okay I
will now ask an audience participation
question hands up if you've heard of
testing
I am in the pesting track at pycon
that's a good sign I found the room
correctly great who's heard of code
coverage
most people if you haven't that's fine
if you have awesome we are going to talk
a little bit about that too okay other
than through the talk and knowing that
it exists who said mutation testing
okay keep your hand up if you've used
mutation testing
gets everyone every time so I'm seeing
some very confident hands at the back
like no I have I'm here to see how you
do it I like that I like the energy I
like that okay so
that's awesome if you have if you
haven't that's fine by the end you will
know what it is and hopefully you'll
feel inspired to use it as well
so before we start let's just kind of
get a bit of a common ground let's talk
about testing so this is an open
question anyone here is welcome to shout
out I don't think the slider will sink
fast enough but why do we write unit
tests this is a question for anyone in
the audience who'd like to shout out why
do we write unit tests
to stay safe or sane
anything else
confidence Inspire confidence I like
that
compliance that's a good one people
don't use the other one yes
oh education I I would say go further
documentation
okay great great thoughts here here's
what I've got so preview code actually
works documentation you get that
confidence we've said all of these
almost regression Tech testing if you do
some refactoring and also for compliance
which people again don't usually get
good work whoever said that but there's
a problem with this right because
projects grow they get bigger it starts
off small it gets bigger it evolves over
time and as you're doing this you might
be refactoring adding new features and
you might find that your code gets
missed you're not actually testing stuff
anymore
you also might find that you often don't
monitor your tests and if you don't
monitor your tests you're going to have
a big problem because in that situation
you are going to be a bit stuck when you
need to understand what they're actually
doing and how much you can trust them
luckily there is a metric that we can
use here and that is code coverage so I
know most people have heard of that but
I'll just give you a quick summary
um this is my opinion this is how I say
it how much of the source code of a
program is executed when the test Suite
is run okay
I'm just going to drink some water
talking about yourselves
thanks
I did this talking Canada last week and
they all started talking at that point I
didn't know I didn't know how to feel
about it so let's give you a real
example so this is um this is basically
an SDK it's one of the sdks I maintained
for my company and it's the one I
applied mutation testing to but we've
also got code coverage
so here's an API example here's just a
file and how code coverage works is
basically you run it and it'll show you
the green stuff here is what we've
tested but you can see there's a red
line here for something that isn't
tested so what this tells me is like oh
shoot I'm not testing that
authentication type I better check that
so then you know I can go away and I can
I can actually make that happen and so I
can test that and this is useful because
code coverage has told me something
useful
what we can also do is have a view of
our overall infrastructure you know all
of our code base and we can see what
we're testing and whatnot and this is
really useful right
this tells us how we can get an eye of
what our tests are doing
so what's good about this well I'll tell
you more and better tests right it can
also be a lot easier or cheap to measure
this stuff you know it's really easy to
just evaluate and go okay so what am I
covering that's that's a really easy
operation to do
it also shows you what you didn't test
and so actually code coverage is pretty
great right
yeah let's hair for code coverage yeah
and so code coverage is important and
it's pretty great right so I think
actually you know what yeah I think
that's fine use code coverage I'll see
you later
um except uh actually actually wait wait
so actually the rest of stuff that's not
so good it can be misleading right and
it also doesn't guarantee the quality of
your tests and so it's at this point I
would like to
um ask for a little bit of uh sincerity
and this is a safe space you can answer
this question honestly I will be
answering this question honestly put
your hand up
if you've ever written a test not
because it was useful but because you
had a code coverage score that you
needed to make higher
safe space it's a safe space half of you
are lying half of you are respect your
honesty
um
so yeah you can see this is a real
problem right this is the real deal and
so we see coverage is great for a lot of
things but it doesn't do everything
so
what can we do here I'll show you an
example this piece of code right it's
very simple I'll just explained we're
importing some requests we're doing one
HTTP call we're doing a get request and
then we're returning the Json of that as
as um you know as a return we're telling
the Json of that response and so I'm
going to show you a on the next slide
this test that I'm about to show you
will give this 100 coverage
now this isn't ideal because all this
does is test that this function
basically is Step through what we don't
do is check the actual payload that
comes back we don't know if we got a 404
we don't know if we got 200 we don't
know what happened here right so this
this isn't it's not useful and that's
what I'm trying to say and actually why
would I say it when I have someone
smarter than me who can so here's good
heart's law so this is a statement that
really summarizes this well this problem
where we end up with code coverage where
we just try and make the number bigger
and it's this it's when a metric becomes
a Target it ceases to be a good metric
I'll say that again when a metric
becomes a Target it stops being a good
metric so if we just think about the
numbers we're not thinking about what
the code coverage is supposed to
actually tell us
does that make sense
awesome okay we see the challenge
so we've got a question here an open
question for the audience to answer
think along at home if you're watching
on the stream how can we understand what
our tests are really doing open question
anybody
read them
good answer
break them even better
and
I started
I found mixed results with that but
maybe the V4 is better I haven't paid
for it yet but
you know there's a really fair points I
think it leads to a further question I
won't answer these just because of time
but how do we know if our tests are
trustworthy is really the question I
think the real summary here was provided
in 100 A.D by the Roman thinkers
juvenile after a fourth glass of wine he
came up with the best statement possible
for this which is who watches the
watches right the tests are supposed to
keep your code safe in production right
but who's watching your tests
I a certain answer for you today
mutation testing spot the odd one out
alrighty you may if your sharpayed have
noticed that Henry's made a comeback so
why why do I keep putting penguins in
these slides you know other than the
fact I think penguins are cute I mean
that's the real answer
um but the the other answer that I'd
like to give is that so the code I work
on deals with like messaging and apis
and so what I was doing when I was
writing this the way I was learning this
myself and the way I was trying to
understand it myself
was that I was thinking about my code
that works is like a pigeon or a dove
it's something where I can tie a message
to its leg
and I can send it off and it'll carry
that message for me
so it'll fly away and do the job so this
in production is like a bird that can
fly away and deliver a message
now penguins are birds that is true but
if you may have noticed it's it's a
reasonably well known fact that Penguins
do not fly it makes them very angry as
you can see so the issue here
yeah it is very sad but I want to show
you why Henry is going to be really
useful to us today and I want to show
you why you should love Henry so this is
what we're going to do
so mutation testing works like this
we start with some production code
we apply some kind of mutation operation
to it
and we end up with a mutant version of
the code so we still got a bird but this
this code is not the same right so the
production code works this code may not
work it does something different
so how does it look in practice well
here's an example
hit this function adds two numbers
Amusement version of this might for
example subtract two numbers
or it might uh it's just playing with
this thing you know it might add an
extra thing extra constants it might
return the string versions of these
things it might return nothing
right these are all these are all valid
and they're all cute ass Penguins so
that's good
so what we do with these how this works
is when we do a mutation test we
generate all of these different things
I call these The Fab Four
um
but we've got these different penguins
that all look a little different they
all they don't fly right they don't do
what they're supposed to do but this is
the situation where you've got Henry
here and Henry is going to try to fly
and what I mean by that is that Henry
here
is going to actually we're going to run
our test Suite with him and we're going
to see if those tests fail now if those
tests fail that's good because he's a
penguin and penguins cannot as we know
fly
but if the test pass
he's too convincing this moves into good
look at these wings
this penguin could carry a bus
that's bad
because it means that this might have
made it to production right
so the question I ask of you is what
does this give us and I'm not actually
asking this of you because time I'd like
to tell you I assert that this gives us
a way to evaluate the quality of our
tests how do we feel about this
awesome we don't have to clap but you
can sure thank you Sarah
I put parts in with audience
participation so I can drink water I'm a
millennial so
let's actually go into something a bit
more nitty-gritty so let's talk about
Frameworks so there's in Python we don't
have like big Enterprise products for
doing mutation testing really like in
you know in like JavaScript or in like
Java we have things
um but in um in Python we've really just
got kind of community supported stuff so
these two these two projects are
community supported these are open
source I'm not affiliated with these um
there's motor cosmic ray and I am not a
doctor I'm not a lawyer I'm not a
professional financial advisor the value
of your investment may go down as well
as up but I personally have been using
mukmud because it just has defaults that
work for me
so let's go all the way back
I've applied this to this code base this
SDK that I own this is what I run and
I've added this in so let me show you
how I actually did that because what I
want is by the end of this is that
everyone here can go home and do this
themselves right
so pip install it super easy right it's
on Pi Pi it's all good
run it and if you've got sensible
defaults this will work if you don't
you're gonna have to do a little bit
more with config and but for this and
what happened when I ran this was I get
a lot of a lot of explanation basically
it will run my test Suite then it will
generate mutants and it will try and run
my test Suite with those mutants
by the way am I talking too fast I'm
aware I talk pretty quickly is this okay
awesome thank you
um I appreciate that most most people
here are having this as a second
language I really appreciate your
patience with me so thank you
um so in in the situation here
um there's a few things that can happen
we can catch these mutants they can time
out they can be a bit suspicious we're
not sure of them and they can also
survive
when I ran this with my code base we
generated nearly 700 mutants
of which we caught 500 and we didn't
catch 170.
is that good or bad I'll tell you later
let's look at some right let's look at
some some mutants that we did catch
first of all so here's one this is just
from this is just something in a class
that I've got and these are just valid
channels that you can send a message
with right
um so a music version of this for
example maybe played with this string so
now SMS is not a valid Channel anymore
and that basically thank you that means
we now have a bit of a challenge
because we can't send a message with
this and so our tests obviously that try
and do that are going to fail so that's
good we catch that mutant here's another
one does anyone use pedantic
a few people awesome I went to a talk
with pedantic yesterday great topic
um so here's a validator this is this is
from pedantic a model that we use in the
SDK
um removing the actual decorator here
this will never be run that's a problem
and so in this case
um we actually catch this one too
you can see mutants that you didn't
catch with what much show you can have a
list of them like this you can see the
range of them you didn't catch and if
you want to see a specific one you will
type much show and then a number and
that will give you
oh dear me that will give you there we
go that will give you a mutant that you
can catch or that you did so this one
you can see was the authentication type
was removed and so this one failed which
is good
you can also see the HTML output so you
can see for example
um the every file and inside of each one
you can see all the mutants you didn't
catch
so let's look at some that we didn't
catch because this is what we want to
see right like we're not here to see a
number we're here to see a mutant that
we want to like do something about
so I'm going to show you three two of
which we maybe don't care about one of
which we do first one here mutant 58 can
we see this the mutant renames the
logger do I care about this
I think no I think logging is out of
scope of what I want to test so I say no
I'm fine with this mutant 62 what have
we done all we've done is we've changed
the value of a constant in a method
signature again I don't care too much
about this so for me this is fine I can
comment these lines out but unless I go
through manually do that I'm fine just
to ignore these mutants right
these aren't problems in production but
let's look at this one
this one is mutant 112 and it is
actually a bit more interesting
because this one here we're
instantiating something from our client
class which is actually how our users
will use that API
and in this case if I remove my entire
voice API class it's fine all the tests
still pass
so how is that okay
right
hey I'm going to remove my voice API
that's fine it's not but we actually
test this directly right
we test it directly and in that that
basically means that actually maybe we
should test this the way that like use
it the way that the client is using it
maybe there is there is a case to write
a valid test there and so now I'm
actually getting real insights about my
code base the coverage was not telling
me does that make sense
thank you for the solemn nodding I
appreciate that
yes yes it does make sense it does it
makes a lot of sense and so
I don't take these that seriously I'm
sorry I care about the code right so we
go back to this number here we didn't
catch all the mutants we cut about 75 of
them I ask you a question is this a good
score
yes this is this is the correct answer
confused shrugging is actually correct
100 does not make sense here because
I've not you know I'm not looking for a
number I'm looking for insight and I've
gotten that Insight from these mutation
tests right
so let's talk about how we get started
with these things
what I did was I started locally and I
started small
if you have a big project you might want
to start with a subset
you might also want to start tweaking
for performance so for example exclude
tests that maybe you're not so
interested in for example tests that
deal with like Integrations things like
databases maybe you don't care about
that and exclude code if you don't need
to run that for example you might want
to exclude Auto generated code because
again you're probably not going to want
to write tests for that
so that's the first part of this
hopefully we understand what mutation
testing is and how we want to use it
Talk Amongst yourselves
I feel like if I got a water company to
sponsor me
that'll be pretty cool because then I
could get paid to do this
anyway I'd like to see you the next
slide I don't know what I typed into
Dali to get this image but I'm really
happy it exists
thank you so you're very kind
um so I'm going to tell you about how
you run this off of your machine
why do you want to do that well this
takes some time like to generate all
these mutants 700 versions of your kind
of like code you know different changes
and then run parts of your test Suite
against those take some time for me that
took me like 15 to 20 minutes
if you do this in the clouds you have to
do this with CI you're using resources
that you don't have to manage and you
can also specify the platforms and
versions that you want so for example
different os's different python versions
all this stuff so if your code is
expected to vary I'll have different
Behavior You may wish to test that too
so I'll show you an example stop talking
you say sorry I can't I'm the only one
with the microphone I'll give one time a
taste in a little bit
um so what did I do I implemented this
in my SDK in GitHub actions because
that's the CI system that I use so we
have this thing here where you can run
this workflow and I've chosen to have
that so it's manually run I don't want
this running on push or PR I'll tell you
why later
um but we run it it does a job and
inside of that it gives us a mutation
test report which is actually the HTML
report of all those mutants that we saw
earlier right
so thank you how did I do it great
question it's not actually that
impressive and I'd like to actually
quickly ask right who's looking at this
right now and thinking I'm gonna I want
to maybe try this this looks pretty cool
I want to maybe have a go at this whoa
this is the most roaring like you know
I've never seen so many enthusiastic
people this is amazing wow awesome
I feel like I'm doing my job right
awesome so if you didn't put your hand
up that's fine because what I'm hoping
is that when I show you how easy it
actually was to make that work you'll be
like oh this guy could do I could do it
you know that's what I want that's what
I want okay so I'll show you with GitHub
actions because that's what I used but
it will be the same pretty much
everywhere because it's just a bit of
scripting
so what do we got
this I'm going to show you the entire
yaml file it's 35 lines I think we can
deal with that I'll talk us through it
so first of all this mutation test we
have this job I'm running on Ubuntu
because I'm basic and I am using python
version 310
um because
um I don't expect my code it doesn't
vary too much from python versions so
I'm okay
so what do we do we check out the code
we set up python
we install our dependencies now
including movement now with added
we then run the mutation test so here
we're running what we're run we've got
two new Flags no progress because we
don't want the output in our logs to get
all disgusting which is what happens and
the CI flag um here which basically
gives us a sensible error code and I'm
going to shout that out because I added
that to motmore it was my only
contribution but I'm still proud of it
um so but it means you can actually run
this in CI without it giving you a
horrible error or hacking it with bash
which is what I used to do so we've got
that we then run the HTML output and we
upload that so you can get hold of it
and that's it that's literally it and
you can see this you can go to my SDK
look at it yourself and just copy paste
it then you'll have it too right so
that's what I would recommend you do
plagiarism so or ask chat GPT and don't
call it plagiarism who knows um so we're
nearly done here so I just want to talk
about
other things you might want to think
about with CI
so manual manual versus automatic
triggering I said that I run this on
push or I don't run this on push rpr I
only run this manually when I choose to
run it now why is that
any thoughts well I drink as well yes
that's good you get the you get the
Tilted head knot of approval
that's a really good point I don't want
to turn this into oh we can't merge this
PR until the mutation score is above you
know 35 whatever you know that that's
just we've just abstracted good heart's
law again we've got the next level of
good hot slow which is not helpful right
what I care about is every now and then
I run these just to see how my code base
is doing right I don't want this to be
something I do all the time it's going
to take ages as well if I want to
quickly register I don't want to wait
for three hours for these things to
build right so I would just say consider
what you're using it for for me it did
not make sense
to do it in that way so you might also
want to think about multiple operating
systems as well you know you can NCIS
you know you can choose what you think
thank you you can choose what you're
using which is cool too
um again I didn't need to for me so you
might want to for your code you can also
use multiple versions of your
dependencies or of other things that you
might need as well so just think about
that when you're considering CI and
that's kind of why You may wish to
consider CI I've also say as well GitHub
action's not sponsored but like you know
my thing's open source so I don't have
to pay for this so if you want to try
out as well do you not care do what you
want um but what I'd like to do now is
just quickly summarize because we aren't
earlier
um we are nearly there so
I just like to say we've been on a
little bit of a wild ride together
usually I'd be running across the stage
there's so much space you know I'd like
to pretend I can cartwheel and have a go
but again the camera won't focus on me
so mutation testing let's summarize it
tests your tests
okay it helps you to beat that good
heart's law situation where you're
turning code coverage into just a metric
that you need to get above a certain
number right it helps you actually think
about why you're testing your tests and
how you get that insight
if you're going to do this I would
suggest starting small and starting
local
starting your machine and go from there
I would also say when you're ready if
you do have your stuff up in CI you
might want to consider running an SEI
system yourself for asynchronous
reporting
finally I would like to say that mutants
themselves right mutants are valuable
and they are wonderful right because
Henry right he's a great penguin right
he may maybe he can't fly but like look
at how much we've gained out of using
Henry to learn about our code base and
he's helped us so much right so what I'd
like to say
is that you shouldn't fear mutants
because you should love them thank you
very much
thank you I just also like to put on
this if you have any feedback or
questions you can tweet me if we don't
get to you today also if you want to
steal my code it's there and if you want
to we're raffling off an Xbox if you
scan the bottom one so if you want to
try and win that we'll announce the draw
in like an hour up to you those will be
on we'll now do some q a thank you yes
thank you very much for your talk um
thank you I think it feels like you
could talk some more minutes about it
um
so unfortunately we haven't any
questions so far while slido
um so is there any question from the
audience just raise your hand I will go
to you and you can ask your question
directly
oh so many
a wonderful presentation
um so how does matmat perform like
reasonable mutations versus unreasonable
is there ways that configurable is that
automatic
yes so you can so the question oh I
don't need to repeat it because we have
the mic right and so I'll repeat it
anyway for me so the question is how do
we choose what mutants I think are
configured is that is that the question
like how do we choose what mutations we
do to our code base
it's also unreasonable mutations such as
like importing some random package
that's not installed right like that's
one reasonable ah got you okay so no
that's that's a really good question so
um inside a movement you can choose the
types of mutations that you do do
um and there are there's actually like
it's again it's pretty community
supported it's not like a nice thing I
mean you're kind of hacking stuff
there's a you know you'll you'll have a
setup.config file which will have your
you know defaults in that you set you
can exclude types of mutations that way
um and then also you can I mean not by
default only kind of has a certain set
of those mutations as well so it's not
going to like do everything possible it
can as long as the code compiles they'll
only be a set of valid ones that are
done and you can add more
um but yeah as it is typically we don't
see that kind of issue with it hopefully
that helps with the question
any other questions
um yes another question would be
um somehow I lost it
um
now they're coming in
how do okay mutants
um that were not caught well I think I
don't know what percentage of living
mutants or false positives on average
what percentage of mutants are false
positives on average
um so I think I think the question I
think what it's getting at is sometimes
we don't care about that mutation you
know like if for example renaming a
logger we don't care about that
um I think I don't know because again
this is something that I learned about
last year and I've started to use myself
this has really been kind of my journey
with her
um again I don't work for movement or
anything it's not something that I I do
myself but what I would say
um is um if that's a concern that you
have
and what I'd say think about is you can
specify parts of your code not to mutate
if you know that you're not going to
want to touch that and you can also
specify entire files and things so you
can basically choose a subset of what
you want to mutate so hopefully that
answers your question I think that's
what it was getting at
thanks for request for the answer I
think this one is also quite interesting
so are the mutations reproducible or is
there some kind of or some level of
Randomness involved sure now these are
deterministic
um yeah what you you set up you'll get
the same number of mutations every time
and um it'll basically go through a
process to work out what is a sensible
mutation and then it will apply those
sensible mutations it will generate a
type of mutant for each one
maybe this is a little bit of a tough
one uh what was the biggest threat
adopting mutation testing what was the
biggest hurdle
um
what's the biggest hurdle in the doctor
mutation for me personally
um
good question I mean uh I had to spend
half a day
and it's really easy you'll have a go
and let go no I mean honestly like um
what would it be probably with the cloud
stuff so the reason I actually ended up
writing a a new flag for was because I
was trying to put this into my CI and
GitHub actions only accepts every exit
code of zero as a success right so if it
returns with a zero good otherwise it
fails but how much returns by default is
um it will give you basically it uses a
bit wise or to give you like you 2468 it
will basically give you a different exit
code depending on the types of mutants
that were left so you'd only ever get a
zero if you never had any mutants that
um that were not caught but that's again
that's not how I use more it's not how
you should use more either or should use
these kinds of tools and so um yeah the
annoying thing there was me basically
spending half a day hacking The Bash to
make it work
um and then being like I'll just I'll
just do it it was actually easy to just
do a PR than it was to just hack The
Bash so probably that honestly
I think we have time for one last short
questions uh question uh the question is
uh 200 false positives to find one bug I
think is um do you think is is it worth
the effort
um that's fair I think um if we take
those numbers at face value of you know
we have to read 200 things and evaluate
each one using the same amount of time
to find a bug like yeah you're right
that's very much like um you know I
wouldn't do that that's not worth it
right but that's not what we're actually
doing because what we're actually doing
is looking at the problem errors and
we're identifying the things that we
think may need a little bit more testing
so we don't give you know the same
weighting to every mutant if we're
looking at oh this is this is logging we
scroll through these are related to the
part where I'm logging I can ignore them
this is related to a function signature
I can ignore those too I could just
comment those out I'm too lazy
um so this this works for me
um so I would go um and say like okay it
depends what you're looking for I would
say as you do this incrementally you
know maybe if you start small and it
adds you know parts of your code if you
add a new feature what I would say to do
in that case would be to um
essentially yeah as you do each new
feature or thing this is how I use it is
to then run and see oh what's changed
since I lasted this because it does
cache your mutants as well so really
it's a bit of an Outlook to go okay
let's sort through work out what these
are telling me and then it's just a
little bit each time when you actually
continue hopefully that answers the
question yes I think so so I think due
to time constraints we unfortunately
have to close the Q a session but I
think Maps is open and happy to answer
some of your further questions and yes
let's thank Max again first before we do
before we do I have a limited run of
python stickers if anyone would like one
come and grab one because I we just got
them for this conference so please come
and take one thank you very much for
having me it's been really thank you
thank you